what's going on there reject nation
craig and john here today we are going
to watch the official train it says
right here
enter the multiverse of unlimited
possibilities
marvel studios what if official trailer
i'm very very much excited for this
sorry for being a little late to this
guys
we decided to catch up on some sleep
today and then mistake
that that bit us in the buttocks yeah we
pulled it all neither the other day to
go check out loki episode five which uh
you can go ahead and check out here on
the channel out of here
let's see what's in store
[Music]
yeah peace i love peace i'd be out of a
job with peace
right back to the first iron man
okay oh it's killmonger
do we know each other
cool
awesome reality
[Applause]
oh nice
not me i get it
[Music]
nice peggy
my name is
[Applause]
there's so much in this trailer ego in
[Applause]
there
i love it
[Applause]
[Applause]
wow that's so great
it's so great hearing all their voices
again let's watch it again
there's so much happening in this
trailer there's so much happening in
this trailer
yeah i love peace i'd be out of a job
with peace
that's not rdj he said it doesn't i'm
pretty sure that is him
sounds like a match to me but hey maybe
i'm wrong
you tell us guys
it's like this is the multiverse of
madness right here
guardians in the avengers
i feel like t'challa and yondu get along
really well oh yeah
like a location in the howard the duck
that's such a great moment there
she looks so badass
zombie iron man
got ego back the ancient one i feel like
we heard her voice earlier today
it looks like the ultrons is it peter's
head in the jar
is that hawkeye as hulk is that what i
saw at one point
did i mistake that
i love how they look like they actually
get along
[Applause]
let's go loki's really been opening up
the door for the multiverse
now to get this official trailer kicking
it off right there with entered the
multiverse it's like
it's begun guys yeah it's officially
begun
it's officially begun this moment was
going by so fast okay that's the
collector
all right all right so the collectors
actually can get out on some of the
action right here or get the
action handed to him yes my biggest
takeaway with it there's a lot of like
fun
swapping happening happening in here and
you are watching alternate versions
transpire like from the very beginning
you have killmonger
in the trailer who helps save tony stark
would that
version of the story still lead to tony
becoming
iron man because the whole point in the
first iron man movie because he was
captured and he had to get himself out
of the cave he had to build the iron man
suit and learn all those things
about what's really going on with stark
industry so is that going to be one
alternate story all dedicated to
killmonger where tony stark never became
iron man but then you also got a moment
in here where you got both
zombies of captain america and iron man
as well so you will get that story of
marvel zombies
you know captain carter looks great the
biggest takeaway that i really had
was with t'challa and yondu with
star-lord and yondu there's such
animosity and tension between the two
odds even though yondu wanted to
maintain being a father figure as part
of the ravagers even though they've
swapped out star-lord with t'challa here
they look like they really get along
yeah
yeah and i mean that's part of the fun
too is is like not only just swapping
out the characters but seeing how
emotionally these personalities might
intermingle
differently i think that would be an
interesting thing to see because
in my mind i wouldn't necessarily think
like oh yeah t'challa and yondu would
get along and yet seeing it here
it makes me really excited for the
possibilities of that and yeah i wonder
i mean to me not to just only use the
loki terminology but i have to imagine
that every one of these scenarios is
going to be its own little branch so
will
tony stark become iron man under
killmonger's you know help and watch
i don't know maybe he'll become a
different iteration of that or some
other
you know version or maybe not at all you
know but yeah that's the fun
uh you know prospect of all this is i
can't wait to see everybody in a context
i'm not used to
you know this was something that like
you know we've had the littlest
glimpse at out of all the like big
marvel announcements of
recent but it's been one that's made me
sort of the most uh
excited and anticipatory this looks like
a total blast i love that they're
on embracing like yep it's the
multiverse anything yes i mean you get a
lot of doctor strange at the beginning
of here you do get some ancient ones
even just slowing it down right now
there's so many images that i did not
catch the first time around it looks
like you're gonna be going back to the
first thor movie
you got the ultron robots here yeah you
got like the uh
guardians of the galaxy in new york
doing the adventures
yeah yeah yeah with the avengers
actually at the guardians i didn't even
notice black panther is in the
background there with him oh
snap so it's like when it swaps it's
guardians thor
and black panther there at the events of
new york city the revengers plus black
panther perfect
i love how loki's leading the army here
looks like a hat he's leading asgard or
something
and that is nick fury right there okay
and then you got wanda here at one point
hey you've got taser face at one point
here in the background
dude episode all about taser face is
howard the duck gonna get a dedicated
episode well at this
point this actually does well and then
this shot here can you guys clarify for
me
with captain carter is captain carter
writing that looks like the first iron
man prototype suit but i'm also like is
that the warmonger suit
as well the one that uh obadiah stain
had i mean it's got the usa marking on
it and it's got a few
gun looking things so i guess my guess
would be
yeah but why is captain carter riding on
the back
like the watchers just looking over all
this kind of pissed off with everything
that's going on all right
okay guys because yeah it's like it
looks like this might actually just be a
direct acknowledgement of
the multiverse of madness with doctor
strange like doctor strange almost seems
like he could be the wrap around all
though
this looks great and yeah it's going to
be chadwick boseman's final appearance
as black panther here and and i like
that
a decent amount of the trailer was
dedicated to him for this uh for his
specific story line and it looks like
it's actually going to be substantial
storytelling for
the character of t'challa in this
alternate universe and that chadwick
bosun is actually going to have a lot to
do voice acting wise i'm very excited
for it all right guys well leave your
thoughts down below
tell us everything we did not point out
russian to get this one up right away
so subscribe click that notification
bell hit that like button you can check
out our loki episode 5 reaction
we'll catch you guys
you